Steve welcome back we are mostly still
in a remote situation but you know it
tell us a bit more about how that well
how this kind of connections working
yeah I mean I thought it'd be
interesting obviously we've talked about
remote working but I mean obviously a
lot of things we're doing is we're using
video conferencing or voice over IP type
software to have conversations with
people not just in a business context
but also with friends and family I mean
I lost track of the number of zoom calls
or FaceTime calls or FaceTime calls for
support Dave that I've had to make in
the past eight weeks or how long we've
been in lockdown I lose track so I
thought it'd be interesting to sort of
talk about the technology that's
involved there because as Steve Jobs put
it when you announced the iPhone 4 and
talked about FaceTime the technology
required to do it it's a bit of an
alphabet soup of technologies that you
need to go through so what I thought we
could do is just spend some time going
over how video conferencing works
this is going to be an overview of
what's involved we'll come back probably
and do some more in-depth videos at
little bits but this one's going to give
the big picture and then we can zoom in
later on to talk about that we're also
going to keep things simple so let's
simplify this problem down to the sort
of conversation we're having now which
is one person talking to another person
will come back and talk about how I have
multiple people but I'm sure you can
guess how we can do it you just have
multiple connections between the
different people to do it and we'll only
consider it going in one direction for
me to Shawn or from Shawn to me because
the other direction is basically the
same in Reverse or well simplify it
right down so we can have a discussion
about what's involved in getting the
voice and pictures from my end to get to
sure what we would call perhaps mouth to
ear how we get the voice from my mouth
to Shawn's ear across all the networks
involved what's actually involved in
setting those things though you're
breaking up there Steve so that again
I'm joking
okay so you mentioned there the the
sound and me hearing what you're saying
but obviously we've got a video elements
of this as well you know important for
YouTube as much as anything but we're
gonna talk about how the video
connection works as well yeah yeah then
we'll talk about video as well but I
think the important thing actually when
you're having these conversations is
that bizarrely even though the video
conference the audio is more important
to following the conversation and having
a sort of natural conversation between
the two people if the audio goes wrong
then you can't hear what's being saying
or the conversation becomes a jumbled
mess or actually even when video is
involved the video signal can break up
or we can drop the quality on it a lot
easier than the audio signal if the
audio signal starts to break up then the
conversation the flow event will brown
down that people start talking over each
other to follow what's being said so
we'll start off looking at the audio and
then we'll talk afterward on that about
how we put video alongside that because
actually once you understand how the
audio works the video signals going in a
very similar way with a very similar set
of problems and you just have to send
video rather than sending audio data
across the network when you rang me this
morning as well as my computer starting
to bleep to tell me that you were trying
to connect also my phone's going how
does that segment of it work how does
how do we know that we want to make a
call it's really two things are involved
with video crosses it's the call set up
which is sort of making sure that Shawn
knows I want to speak to him and that he
accepts the call and then we also need
to establish how we actually said that
between the two of us and he's also
actually sending the data over the
connection so taking the audio in the
video that we would send and actually
sends them over the Internet and I think
it's easier to talk about how we send
the data first and then we'll look at
how we do call setup and what's involved
in that in another video because that
actually involves making sure we can get
the data to each other that's when you
can have data sent then we know the
problems that are involved with sending
the data talking about how we transfer
there's loads of things that involve
this it may seem like a simple thing to
just take a piece of audio and send it
over and over but actually when you
think about what's involved in making
this into a conversation and not just a
live stream this in the live stream I'm
just sending data to Shawn or whoever's
watching and they're enjoying whatever
it is insert your favorite type of
YouTube live stream here but with a
voice over IP or a videoconference we're
having a conversation and so we need to
make sure that the connection we've got
enables the conversation to happen as if
the technology wasn't there we don't the
technology to get in the way of what
we're doing and so we need to think
about things like how much bandwidth is
this going to take I mean we've all got
network connections but they have a fine
and amount of data that we can send I
mean in an ideal world we wouldn't worry
about it we could just send all the data
coming from the microphone coming from
the camera straight down the network and
it would appear at Shawn's and
everything would just get there and it
would work so basically what we're
saying is that we need to shrink that
down before it goes through connections
so that we're not sending too much data
and clogging it up and causing latency
right yes I mean we've got oodles of
data coming the video I mean the audio
for recording sort of CD quality audio
is about 768 kilobits per second so
we've got a lot of data going down and
and okay a modern network connection my
home networks 300 megabits down thirty
five megabits up a gigabit symetrical
isn't unheard of these days in a home
setting
but that's still a lot of data and so
obviously we need to sort of compress
whatever we've got or need to make sure
whatever we send fits within the
bandwidth we've got available because
it's not just our bandwidth its your
bandwidth as well I've probably got a
better internet connection than you know
you have I know that you have we've done
tests in transferring material back and
forth that proves that but yeah but the
point is I suppose there's even more
considerations that you might live in a
household with four or five people
someone who's streaming your movie at
the same time someone else who's trying
to make their own call so yeah there are
all sorts of considerations aren't that
yes there's lots of things that fed the
bandwidth is who else in the house is
using it is what you've got what I've
got there's what's involved in the
network between it if the network gets
congested then the bandwidth will drop
even though each end is technically king
capable of sending that so we need to
take that into account so the bandwidth
is important because we need to make
sure that we can actually send the data
that were not trying to force too much
down the pipe as it were to the other
end what also is important is the
latency all the time it takes for me
saying something coming out of my mouth
- Shaun hearing it through his ear or
what's known as the mouth to ear time so
the mouth to ear time or the latency of
the connection is one of the key issues
that we need to minimize the telecoms
industry found many years ago that
actually as long as it's below 100
milliseconds the conversation will
follow naturally people be I'll have a
conversation as if it's not there so we
want to try and minimize that as much as
possible if it goes above 100
milliseconds then the conversation
starts to break down because I think
you've finished speaking I start
speaking but because of the delay you
think I'm not going to say anything and
starts saying something and we start
talking over each other then we stop and
then we both start speaking again at the
same time and as it goes on and very
quickly once the latency goes above 100
milliseconds the conversation will sort
of break down into a Shawn do you copy
over yes receiving over good out we want
to make sure whatever we do we minimize
the latency so the network itself has
some inherent latency in it you can
measure that by running the
and on your computer and seeing how long
it takes to get from your computer to
another and back and then have it and
that shows you the latency on that
network connection but this is also
related to bandwidth but not directly if
you bandwidth increases your legacy will
go down but it can also go up and the
other thing to bear in mind is that
you're never going to get away with zero
latency and actually we expect latency
in a conversation so as we sit two
meters apart as we all socially distance
there's a natural delay as the sound
waves propagate from my mouth to
someone's ear so there's always an
latency in the conversation what we want
to ensure is that whatever we do doesn't
introduces any more plates and seeing
some of the things we might do to say
preserve bandwidth are going to increase
latency and so we want to balance what
we do there with what we do to maintain
latency so I'm actually better to to use
more bandwidth and have less latency or
to go for a slightly worse compression
and have a sort of algorithm that
compresses not as well as it could to
reduce latency you want to sort of try
and keep the latency down as low as
possible the other thing you want to
take into account is a vsync so we want
to make sure that the words coming out
of my mouth are in sync with the
pictures as they aren't at the moment
because when that happens it becomes
really hard to follow what's going on it
looks old so we want to also try and
maintain sync between what I'm saying
and the video and of course because
they're going to go through different
routes cause we're going to compress the
video in a different way to the way we
can press the audio we've got to be able
to pair them up back at the other end so
that they appear in sync and again that
will affect latency because if it takes
longer to compress the video than it
does to send the audio then we have to
delay one at the other end so that we
can match them so latency is a really
important thing in a video consoling we
want to try and minimize that as
possible and lots of the things that
happen are involved in minimizing the
latency of connection other things you
need to take care on is that if you
think about the way the school is
working I'm speaking to Sean it's coming
out of his loudspeaker or through his
earpiece in my case and the insurance
case but if that's coming through the
speaker that will get picked up again
rather microphone
this video is either suppressing the
echo by sort of muting one end of the
conversation when that person is
speaking or you can create circuits
which counsel the echo by sort of taking
the signal that's coming in and feeding
it back and sort of in anti face to sort
of cancel out what's going on there
there's lots of math involved in that
bilasa still in for someone else in
another video to cover so we can't we
have to take all these things into
account and of course as the legacy
increases the echo will get more
noticeable so things in fact there's one
networking standard way of its package
size was created purely on the amount of
time that you get from one end of France
to the other without leading echo
counseling so they went for 53 bytes or
something but that's another story ATMs
are complete other networking topic that
we'll talk about at some point so we're
going to maintain bandwidth we need to
make sure we fit within what's available
on the network or less if other people
using it and again that can change you
might start a conversation and then
someone starts watching Netflix on the
same network connection or the network
may get congested elsewhere and the path
between you and your the person is lots
of people on the same ISP start watching
the latest cat video on YouTube or
whatever it is people do one YouTube
this computer file video of course are
more interesting than cats we have mice
so these things will change we need to
match that in our system but we also
need to keep the latency down and we
need to maintain a vsync so how do we go
about building a system let's sir let's
start drawing a diagram with the bits
that are involved we're going to talk
about how we get the voice from me here
to Sean over there so it Sean's end we
have something that looks a bit like an
ear and over at my things we have
something that looks a bit like two lips
that has changed colour and we're now
going to talk about how we can send a
signal from there to that if we just
start building this up as we go the
easiest ways that we'd have some sort of
microphone at this end and we'd have a
loudspeaker but Sean's end and then we
could just connect a wire between the
two and as I speak the microphone cover
my voice into an audio signal electrical
signal that represents the same waveform
as my voice sends it down the cable and
that at the other end the last speaker
converts our back into sound pressure
waves that Sean then hears this is a
standard plain old telephone system it's
exactly how that worked so the cable was
sort of controlled by switches but
effectively once it was said of you had
a connection between the two but we're
talking about sending this over
computers so we're going to end up
having to send this digitally so what
we're going to end up doing is taking
the signal out of the microphone and
then we're going to run that through an
A to D converter and what we get out of
the other end is a series of bytes that
will represent that audio signal it's a
mono signal so we'll get a single stream
of bytes that represent that and we can
adjust the quality here by choosing the
sample rate and how many bits we use to
represent the audio so he go for sort of
CD quality sound or better which would
give us a lot of J to the send or we
could sort of do what the phone company
originally did was only sample it at a
kilohertz which is two times for killers
which is the highest frequency you
normally get in a voice signal and so
you capture all the data required for
voice you don't see anything else and
you use eight bits which gives you
64,000 bits per second so that's going
to give us a set of data bytes and
they're going to come every 8,000 sort
of second let's just go with that to
keep the numbers simple so every 8,000
was second we're going to get another
byte of data representing my voice and
so that's going to come out as a change
and as the other end again we have the
opposite so we'll have a D to a
converter digital to analog which
regenerates the analog signal which
could drive the Apple on speaker and we
can then send this across and it would
all work with digitize did but we still
need that cable in there so what do we
do
well we need to send this over our
network and that worked the internet in
is packet-based there's been a long
debate between
telecoms people to go for sort of
circuit switched networks or do you go
for a Datagram packet based networks
where you just put things in a packet
graph then pack it and send it like
you're sending a letter to the right
person
packets seem to have run out sort of
circuits which ones like ATM and so on
seem to have pretty much
I doubt or used to send packets over
them anyway so a girl build them up into
packets but now we've got an interesting
problem we've got data coming every
eight thousandths of a second from the A
to D converter and we need to put them
into a packet so if we just go to say a
thousand samples that would be one
eighth of a second at 8,000 kilohertz
sampling rates that's over one 100
milliseconds there so we probably want
to choose a smaller packet size so as
soon as we start building these things
up into a packet we've got to wait for
the right number of bytes to come in
before we can send the packet out that's
going to introduce some latency so we
need to make sure we choose a packet
size that is small enough to not
introduce too much latency so let's say
we just had one byte in each packet well
we could send that over that would mean
we didn't have any latency but we don't
have a situation where you'd be wasting
bandwidth because that one byte would
have several bites of packet headers on
there for the sort of IP header and so
on that you would need to send send it
across so that'd be very wasteful so you
want some that so you need to choose the
right number of bytes to make this sort
of right there so if your may be too
many then you'll use your bandwidth
better but you'll increase your latency
so you have to sort of rob Peter to pay
Paul that to find the right thing and of
course it's the network changes those
conditions will change so you may have
to change that as the things going on
there so we're suddenly going to get a
delay here and by building things into a
packets and then you get that packet at
the other end and you take the bite out
of that one-by-one and feed them to your
D to a converter there's still an issue
here is we send that over the network
you're taking the data in the packet and
you're reading out the bites one by one
sending them to do your d/a-converter
1/8 for every eight thousandth of a
second so we can send that but when you
come to the end of the packet you need
to make sure that you've got the next
packet with the next set of bytes over
there at the next one eight thousandth
of a second later if it's if it comes
later than that you haven't got the data
so you can't send it out to the
d/a-converter what do you do well you
end up having to play
silence or whatever so we need it there
one eight thousand a second but if you
backtrack to my end of the connection to
send that I can only send that when the
network conditions are clear so if I'm
sending another packet let's say I've
got a 1500 byte packet from a network
transfer where I'm sending this video to
you Shaun at the same time that's just
started that's going to take some time
to send I can't send my packet of data
with the audio connection until that's
finished sending which will delay it a
bit more and then which will delay it at
the other end so actually although we've
got the packets there we're going to end
up with some sort of buffering after
that just because the network will be
being used to other things and actually
every step along and that works going to
introduce some buffering as well that
means that your end is a very good
chance that you haven't got the data you
need to free to your d/a-converter when
you finish going through that packet so
we need to put something in place to
make that work and the way we can do
that typically say in a live stream
thing is that we actually put a buffer
here and we just start buffering or
queuing up those packets so let me know
we've got two or three in memory all the
time so that if the mother arrives late
it goes on the end of the queue and then
by the time we come to it we've got to
that point but that introduces more
delay so we're gonna do make sure that
the buffer there is as small as possible
perhaps two or three packets and that
packet size is small enough so that we
don't notice that additional latency we
introduced there but there's another
issue here and if you think back to the
video we did on VPN we talked about how
there's two ways we can send data over
the network we can either say use a TCP
connection which tries to emulator a
stream between the two connections where
we send every byte down there and it
arrives at the other end guaranteed one
after the other in the order they're
sent ma'am I think that's great that's
exactly what we want for an audio
conversation we want all the data to get
there so that you can hear everything I
said but if you remember the way we said
that does that is that TCP if it doesn't
receive something we'll wait and then
ask for it to be sent again and then
it'll say
again and if that happens that's going
to delay that packet arriving and
because it's guaranteed everything is
happening in order after that every
other byte will be delayed by that point
and so the latency will increase and as
packets will get lost on the internet
because it's a best-effort network is
guaranteed to lose packets then we'll be
getting packets lost and lost and lost
and so the latency of the conversation
will creep up and up and up
imperceptibly but eventually by the end
it could have got to a point where you
can notice it so TCP actually perhaps
isn't as good an idea for sending it as
you think the alternative way we can
send that it is say just to send the
packets out there and let the computer
do its best to get there and if they get
lost they get lost and actually it turns
out that it's certainly for audio and
also for video this isn't as much of a
problem as you might expect because we
think about it if we're packet size is
small enough let's say we're sending 80
bytes that's one hundredth of a second
if it's a 100th of a second dropout
where the packet gets lost on the audio
you're probably not going to hear it
you'll be able to pick up the sort of
conversation as things are going and the
next packet will come along and so all
you'll get is a sort of small bit of
silence are you hearing this bit now and
actually that's that's quite natural to
us because as we're having conversations
there are other sounds that we're here
which might cover a bit of the
conversation and so we're used to those
sort of things so actually it's better
to have packets going missing and then
just carry on and deal with what we've
got and deal with that then to actually
try and guarantee everything's going
there so when we send these things out
we want to send them using UDP rather
than TCP because that was passed to get
lost as we said we're not going to know
if you've sat in a conversation wise we
would start to notice the buildup of
latency as the TCP connections started
delaying things as everything got resent
and resent and resent and resent and so
on so we we use UDP number rather than
just stuffing the data into the UDP
packet as is we actually prepend to the
data another header there this time for
what's called the real-time transport
protocol and this just gives some
details about what type of data
this stream of packets is it audio is it
video what codec is it using to compress
things and so on but it also has a
source identifier in there so that we
know that this is coming from the same
stream settle to see unique randomly
generated ID for a stream that says
these packets are all coming from the
same source stream the same audio per
stream or the same video stream so you
can sort of multiplex certain things and
we also have a sequence number in there
so we know whether packets have got lost
or what order then you don't conceal
things to bear in mind is that the
network might reorder things because
they go different routes in which case
you want to reorder them ourselves back
into the correct order otherwise we'll
get the audio jumbled up and if we're
buffering things we get the opportunity
to do this or we can just drop the
packets if they come out of order and so
on but also we have a time stamp on
there which tells us when this should be
played of time it says when either when
he came from or when it should be played
and this is what we use later to
synchronize the video to the audio we
stamped the audio of the time it came
from we start the video of the time it
came from and that tells us when the
first byte in that packet should be
played out that works fine when the data
rates are low it said like with 64,000
bits per second that's reasonable to
send over know what connection even in
the 1980s on something like ISDN but
just but if you want to do better
quality earlier because that isn't that
good quality audio say what you have CD
quality audio we're going to have
significantly more data we need to
compress that down to a smaller size in
some way so that we can send it over the
network connection and when we do that
it's dead simple we can just sit in
between the ad converter and the packet
izing beats of the section and take that
data and compress it and at the other
end after you've read it out the packet
rather than sending it straight to the
DM which would sound horrible
you can sort of decompress it at that
point but again compressing it you're
gonna have to gather the data together
look at you analyze it and
decide how you gonna throw things away
because that's what compression is it's
working out well I can throw this
information away or and still recover
the original signal or something that
sounds like V or looks like the original
signal and again when you do compressor
you're going to have the same sort of
process the other end so you can end up
introducing more delay and increase the
latency at each end so you've got a
balance for these things to try and keep
the latency as far below milliseconds as
you can to try and keep the conversation
as natural as possible as we're sending
this across the other thing we have to
bear in mind is that this isn't going to
be stable every packet we send is going
to take a slightly different amount of
time to send that's what's called jitter
on the line since we're not about of
constant latency okay the constant
latency we could probably calculate
easily but actually the latency will
change as we're sending packets across
there as we've said so I might start
using it to watch a Netflix or the
iPlayer or something it might take a
different route over the network so one
packet may take two milliseconds to get
there the next one might take 2.1 the
next one might take 1.9 depending on
various frets on their work so you need
to have the buffering in place to cope
with these sort of things and things and
also to monitor and adapt actually the
compression rate of things start to get
more latent you can press it less or
when you've got more bandwidth you
compress it more so you've got smaller
packets so you've got more chance of
them going through so whatever is
happening to try maintain the call
quality but you want to keep the blatant
C as low as possible as you're doing
this so that sound your audio and we can
do the same in the opposite directions
so that Shawn can talk to me as I said
we perhaps a bit of echo cancellation in
there which again is going to delay
things a bit as we process that it's
really weird if you do start to hear the
legs on your own voice when having
conversation if you start to play your
own voice with an even a sort of 10
millisecond delay it will really change
the way you speed you end up slowing
yourself down as you hear the delay and
it's really strange so that's how we can
send the audio but what about video what
it works
pretty much the same way we have a
camera that captures a picture that's
going to capture 60 frames per second 50
frames per second 25 frames even as low
as 12 frames per second as we're sending
the data across and again we're then
going to need to compress that down
because the video stream is likely to be
unless we got a really fabulous
bespoke videoconferencing setup where
we've got guaranteed bandwidth between
the two things hd-sdi lines or whatever
it is we've so laid down we're gonna
have to compress and even you've got it
probably on and still compress it down
to a smaller size and that's going to
take time and then we send that across
and we do send this across with time
stats sequence number and then we can
rebuild that at the other end to display
it on screen in the same way we do with
the audio one of the things we can do
though because we know the images are
going to change so much in a typical
video conferencing the background behind
me started with background behind Sean's
static so we can use interframe
compression and throw bits of
information away that doesn't change
from frame to frame some example the
background but the way we'd normally do
that is by working on the sequence of 15
frames so 30 frames or 60 frames and
compressing them all in one go just
going to introduce the delay so we need
to make sure that we design our coder
that it doesn't introduce those delays
and you can start to do even more things
like for example breaking the image down
into so for example slices so that you
can compress the top slide first which
if you're building the hardware from
scratch will often come from the sensor
before the bottom half if the machine is
multi-threaded I've got a hardware
support we can can be compressing one
slice while we're sending the other over
the network so we can reduce the latency
even more and when you've received at
the other end of the conversation we can
synchronize it with the audio using the
time stamps in the RTP headers that tell
us when this was came from and so we can
match them up delaying each of them as
needed so they can be played out in sync
to whoever's watching the video
conference and the same can happen in
Reverse we can now set the data over the
network we've got
an RTP stream containing the audio an
RTP stream containing the video the very
few have timestamps in them so we can
sort of synchronize that the problem
we've got and this is because of how the
Internet's develop this is too many
people using it it's how we make sure
that we know we're sending this to the
right computer particularly is there
likely to be hidden between network
address translation and firewalls and so
on so in another video how we set up the
call and how we can make sure that my
computer behind my network and my home
address translation could talk to
Shaun's computer behind his net Rooter
and his network address translation and
our one things me more simple if we just
wait to ipv6 you only have to work out
whether it's worth alerting the user if
you find the key so you know you
download the temporary exposure key you
perform that the encryption you generate
the potential RPI's and you compare them
with the ones you've seen and/or if you
want a more a slightly comprehensible
message it's saying maybe you haven't
applied a function to enough arguments